wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
du solltest antworten
ich weiß nicht aber du hast doch gesagt
ist ein charmanter netter mann ja das
stimmt doch alles und wir hatten einen
wunderbaren abend zusammen also lag
erinnert mich so an günter er erinnert
sich an ein ehemann günther war nicht
nur mein ehemann
er war auch mein bester freund zuerst
haben wir freundschaft geschlossen
und dann haben wir uns verliebt und wir
hatten eine wunderbare gemeinsame zeit
und hatte geheiratet
ziemlich spät wir waren sehr lange
verlobt geheiratet haben wir 1993 93 ich
trage immer noch seinen ehering hat mich
so daran gewöhnt was ist mit jörg ich
glaube er hat gesagt er ist geschieden
seine frau hat ihn verlassen sie hatten
viel streit
ihr seid also beide allein das leben
geht weiter
das hat günter auch immer gesagt na also